la compare à d'autres décennies, et les années 2000
restent la seule décennie de l'histoire affichant un taux d'emploi
en fin de la décennie inférieur à celui
en début de décennie. Ce n'est pas beau à voir.
Quand on corrèle le nombre d'employés potentiels
au nombre d'emplois disponible dans le pays, on voit que la différence
s'élargit de plus en plus au fil des années, et puis,
pendant la Grande Dépression, elle grossit énormément.
J'ai fait quelques rapides calculs. J'ai pris le taux de croissance du PIB des 20 dernières années
et le taux de croissance de la productivité des travailleurs
que j'ai corrélé de façon assez directe
de manière à estimer combien d'emplois l'économie allait
nécessiter pour continuer sa croissance, and je me retrouve avec cette courbe.
Alors est-ce que c'est positif ou négatif ? C'est la prévision du gouvernement
en ce qui concerne la future population active.
Si ces estimations sont correctes, ce vide ne risque pas de se combler.
Le problème c'est que, je ne pense pas que ces estimations soient correctes.
En particulier, je pense que mon estimation est bien trop optimiste,
pour la bonne raison que quand je l'ai faite, j'ai pris pour hypothèse que le futur
allait plus ou moins ressembler au passé
en ce qui concerne l'augmentation de productivité des travailleurs, et ce n'est pas vraiment mon opinion,
parce que quand je regarde autour de nous, je me dis qu'on a encore rien vu.
en matière d'impacts de nouvelles technologies sur la productivité des travailleurs.
Ces derniers temps, en l'espace de quelques années, nous avons vu l'apparition d'outils numériques
démontrant des compétences et aptitudes jamais vu auparavant,
et cette évolution vient modifier grandement la façon dont nous autres humains
gagnons notre vie. Laissez-moi vous donner quelques exemples.
Au cours de l'histoire, si vous vouliez traduire quelque chose
d'un langage à un autre,
il fallait faire appel à un être humain.
Aujourd'hui, on trouve des services de traduction automatique,
multi-langues, instantanés et gratuits
sur la plupart de nos gadgets, y compris nos smartphones.
Et pour ceux d'entre nous qui les avons utilisés, nous savons
que ce n'est pas parfait, mais relativement correct.
Depuis la nuit des temps, si vous vouliez écrire quelque chose,
un rapport ou un article, il fallait toujours faire appel à quelqu'un.
Plus maintenant. Ceci est un article paru il a y quelques temps
dans la version online de Forbes, sur les revenus d'Apple.
Il a été écrit par un algorithme.
Et ce n'est pas seulement décent, c'est parfait.
Après avoir vu ça, beaucoup de gens diront, « D'accord,
mais ces tâches sont très spécifiques, très limitées,
quand la plupart des travailleurs du savoir sont des généralistes,
et ce qu'ils font consistent à intégrer une très grande quantité
d'expertises et de connaissances qu'ils utilisent
pour réagir et improviser face à des problèmes imprévisibles,
et ça, c'est très difficile à automatiser. »
L'un des meilleurs travailleurs du savoir
quand on parle de mémorisation, s'appelle Ken Jennings.
Il a gagné le jeu télévisé « Jeopardy ! » 74 fois d'affilé,
en remportant 3 millions de dollars.
A droite, on peut voir Ken se faire battre à plat de couture par
Watson, le superordinateur programmé par IBM pour jouer à « Jeopardy ! ».
Alors quand on jette un œil à ce que la technologie peut faire
face aux travailleurs du savoir, je commence à penser
que cette idée du généraliste n'a rien de spécial
particulièrement quand on passe à la vitesse supérieure
et on connecte Siri à Watson pour obtenir une machine
qui peut comprendre ce qu'on dit
et nous le répéter.
Siri est loin d'être parfait et on peut se moquer
de ses défauts, mais on doit aussi garder à l'esprit que
si des machines comme Siri et Watson s'améliorent
conformément à la loi de Moore, ce qu'elles feront,
d'ici six ans, elles ne seront pas seulement deux fois plus perfectionnées
ou quatre fois plus, elles seront 16 fois plus efficaces qu'aujourd'hui.
Alors je commence à me dire qu'une grande portion du travail lié au savoir va être affecté par cela.
Et les technologies numériques n'affectent pas seulement le travail lié au savoir.
Mais commencent à se faire la main sur le monde réel.
Il y a quelques temps, j'ai eu la chance de faire un tour
dans la voiture autonome conçue par Google, qui est aussi cool que son nom l'indique. (Rires)
Et je me porte témoin, elle a fait face aux embouteillages
de l'U.S. 101 sans problèmes.
Il y a environ trois millions et demi de personnes
qui conduisent des camions pour gagner leur vie.
Je pense que certains d'entre eux vont être affectés par cette technologie.
Et au jour d'aujourd'hui les robots humanoïdes n'en sont
qu'à un stade très primitif. Ils ne peuvent pas faire grand-chose.
Mais ils s'améliorent très rapidement, et DARPA,
la filiale d'investissement du département de défense
tente d'accélérer cette trajectoire.
Alors, en résumé, oui, les machines en veulent à nos emplois.
Dans l'immédiat, on peut stimuler les créations d'emplois
en encourageant les entrepreneurs et en investissant
dans l'infrastructure, parce que les robots d'aujourd'hui
ont toujours du mal à réparer les ponts.
Mais tantôt, peut-être même du vivant
de la plupart des personnes présentes aujourd'hui, nous allons effectuer une transition
vers une économie très productive mais qui
ne nécessite pas beaucoup de travailleurs humains,
et la gestion de cette transition reste
le plus grand défi auquel notre société se verra confrontée.
Voltaire synthétisa le pourquoi. Il a dit, « Le travail
éloigne de nous trois grands maux: l'ennui, le vice et le besoin. »
Mais malgré ce défi, je suis personnellement,
très optimiste en ce qui concerne la technologie numérique, et je crois
fermement que les technologies numériques que nous sommes en train
de développer nous mèneront bien vers un future utopique,
et non pas dystopien. Et pour expliquer pourquoi,
je voudrais poser une question ridiculement générale.
Je veux demander quel fut le développement
le plus important de l'histoire humaine ?
Maintenant, je voudrais partager quelques-unes des réponses
à cette question qui m'ont été données. C'est une excellente question
pour initier un débat sans fin,
parce que certaines personnes iront parler
des systèmes philosophiques occidentaux et orientaux qui
ont changé notre vision du monde.
Et puis d'autres viendront dire, « Non, au contraire, les grandes histoires,
les grands développements restent l'invention des
principales religions, qui ont façonné les civilisations
et ont changé et influencé la façon dont laquelle un nombre incalculable de gens
vivent leur vie. » Et puis d'autres diront,
« En fait, ce qui façonne les civilisations, ce qui les modifie
et ce qui change réellement la vie des gens
ce sont les empires, si bien les développements les plus importants de l'histoire humaine
restent liés aux conquêtes et aux guerres. »
Et puis finalement, un coeur joyeux viendra toujours
s'écrier, « Eh, n'oubliez pas la peste. » (Rires)
Il existe aussi de nombreuses réponses optimistes à cette question
alors certaines personnes nous parleront des Grandes Découvertes
et l'ouverture du monde.
D'autres parleront de performances intellectuelles
dans des disciplines telles que les mathématiques qui nous ont permis
d'obtenir une meilleure compréhension du monde, et d'autres viendront parler
des périodes de prospérité en ce qui concerne
les arts et les sciences. Au final, ce débat ne sera jamais terminé.
C'est un débat sans fin, et il n'existe aucune,
bonne réponse. Mais si comme moi, vous êtes un geek,
vous allez dire, « Eh bien, qu'est-ce que les données disent ? »
Et là vous commencez à construire des graphiques
potentiellement intéressant, la population mondiale par exemple
ou une mesure du développement social,
ou bien du stade d'avancement d'une société,
et vous commencez à tracer des courbes, parce que, à travers cette approche,
les grandes histoires, les grands développements de l'histoire humaine,
sont ceux qui viennent déformer ces courbes.
vous allez rapidement être amené à tirer d'étranges conclusions.
vous allez rapidement être amener à tirer d'étranges conclusions.
Vous conclurez, qu'en réalité, aucune de ces choses
n'ont eu d'importance. (Rires)
Ils n'ont pas eu le moindre effet sur ces courbes. (Rires)
Il y a eu une histoire, un développement
au cours de l'histoire humaine qui a modifié la trajectoire de la courbe
de 90 degrés, et c'est l'histoire de la technologie.
La locomotive à vapeur, et autres technologies
associées à la Révolution Industrielle ont changé le monde
et influencé l'histoire humaine, tellement que,
empruntant les mots de l'historien Ian Morris,
ils ont tourné au ridicule tout ce qui s'est passé auparavant.
Et ils ont fait cela en multipliant indéfiniment la puissance
de nos muscles, dépassant leurs limites naturelles.
Maintenant, là où nous en sommes
c'est d'essayer de dépasser les limites de notre cerveau
pour venir multiplier indéfiniment notre puissance mentale.
Comment est-ce que cela pourrait être moins important
que dépasser nos limites musculaires ?
Au risque de me répéter, quand je jette un œil
aux récentes évolutions des technologies numériques,
nous n'en sommes qu'au début,
et quand je jette un œil à ce qui se passe en ce qui concerne nos économies
et nos sociétés, la seule chose que je peux conclure
c'est qu'on n’a encore rien vu. Les meilleurs jours sont à venir.
Laissez-moi vous donner quelques exemples.
On n’alimente pas notre économie avec de l'énergie. Encore moins avec du capital,
non plus avec de la main d'oeuvre. Nos économies sont alimentées par des idées.
Alors, le travail d'innovation, la tâche qui consiste à avoir
de nouvelles idées, est l'un des travaux les plus importants,
l'un des travaux fondamentaux auquel nous puissions nous adonner
dans notre économie. Et c'est un peu de cette façon qu'on avait l'habitude d'innover.
On irait trouver une poignée de personnes qui se ressemblent.
-- (Rires) --
on les exporterait d'une institution d'élite à une autre
et puis il ne resterait qu'à attendre qu'ils innovent.
Maintenant -- (Rires) --
en tant que caucasien ayant passé la totalité de sa carrière au MIT
et à Harvard, ça me va parfaitement. (Rires)
Mais ça ne va pas à d'autres personnes, et ils ont en quelque sorte fini par s'inviter
à la fête et décontracter le code vestimentaire de l'innovation.
(Rires)
Alors voici les vainqueurs d'un concours de programmation Top Coder,
et je peux vous assurer que personne n'attribue d'importance
à l'endroit où ils ont grandi, leur école,
ou bien leur apparence. La seule chose qui a de l'importance,
c'est la qualité de leur travail, la qualité de leurs idées.
Et une fois encore, on observe ce phénomène
dans un monde fait de technologie.
Le travail lié à l'innovation est en train de devenir plus ouvert,
moins élitiste, plus transparent, et plus méritoire,
et ça va continuer peu importe ce que le MIT et Harvard
vont en penser, et ce développement ne pourrait me rendre plus heureux.
J'ai entendu il y a quelque temps, « D'accord, je vous l'accorde,
mais la technologie moderne reste un outil seulement à disposition du monde développé,
et ce qui n'est pas en train de se passer, cette technologie numérique
n'améliore pas la vie des personnes vivant aux pieds de la pyramide. »
Et je voudrais adresser cet argument d'une façon très claire: absurdité.
Ceux aux pieds de la pyramide profitent grandement de cette technologie.
L'économiste Robert Jensen a conduit cette incroyable étude,
il y a quelques temps, il a observé précisément
l'évolution du village de pécheur de Kerala, en Inde,
suite à l'apparition de téléphones mobiles,
et quand vous écrivez pour le Quarterly Journal of Economics,
vous êtes obligé d'utiliser un vocabulaire très sec et circonspect,
mais quand j'ai lu cet article, j'ai eu la sensation que Jensen était en train d'essayer
de nous alerter, et de dire, écoutez, c'était énorme.
Les prix se sont stabilisés, et les gens ont pu commencer à planifier leur vie économique.
Les déchets n'ont pas été réduits, ils ont disparu.
Et le niveau de vie des acheteurs et des vendeurs
de ce village, s'est considérablement amélioré.
Maintenant, je ne pense pas que Jensen ait atterri par chance
dans l'un des rares villages
où la technologie viendrait améliorer le niveau de vie.
Je pense au contraire, qu'il a attentivement documenté
un phénomène global qui se reproduit à chaque fois que la technologie
fait son apparition dans une communauté et son environnement.
Le niveau de vie des habitants, leurs bien-être, s'est amélioré de façon spectaculaire.
Alors quand je me retrouve face à toutes ces preuves, et que je pense
à toute les possibilités que nous avons, je deviens définitivement
un optimise numérique, et je commence à penser que cet incroyable
citation du physicien Freeman Dyson
n'est pas seulement une hyperbole. C'est une juste estimation de ce qui est en train de se passer.
nos technologies numériques sont un don,
et dès maintenant, nous avons la chance
de vivre à une époque où la technologie numérique est florissante,
en pleine expansion, et en train de devenir
plus approfondie partout dans le monde.
Alors oui, les machines nous piquent nos emplois,
mais rester focalisé sur ce point nous égare complètement.
Ce qui est important, c'est que cette nouvelle disponibilité nous permet de faire d'autres choses,
et ce que nous allons faire, et j'en suis convaincu,
c'est d'aller réduire la pauvreté, les tâches ingrates,
et la misère partout dans le monde. Je suis convaincu
que nous allons apprendre à vivre plus légèrement sur cette planète,
et je suis absolument convaincu que ce que nous allons faire
de ces nouveaux outils numériques, sera tellement novateur
et tellement bénéfique que ça viendra tourner au ridicule
tous ce que s'est passé auparavant.
Je vais laisser le dernier mot à quelqu'un qui est
à l'avant-garde de cette révolution numérique,
notre vieil ami Ken Jennings. Je le soutiens.
Je ne ferai que le citer:
« Je souhaite la bienvenue à notre nouveau chef suprême numérique. » (Rires)
Merci beaucoup. (Applaudissements)